[Music]
it was a long walk for this family the
longest walk of their lives
Marius niranjan Fernando was killed in a
bomb attack in Saint Sebastian's Church
in the Goblin his sister followed the
cart that carried his coffin she's
crying out asking why God is punishing
them or remembering how many times she
and his brother and his father they were
only the first car in a long procession
from the same church there was attacked
just two days ago we've been walking
from the church along with this funeral
procession as one car I had both there
many cars behind as many people walking
with us you can see the grief on their
faces you can hear it in their voices
they insisted on carrying him as they
came closer to his final place of links
[Music]
this was the mass grave freshly
excavated ready for a mass burial coffin
after coffin each family bearing the
same devastating payment today I counted
26 crosses set aside for buries the
coffins were tagged to the bodies and
their multitude would not be confused
first by hand then by spade there are so
many that a team of mechanical diggers
has to move the rest of the earth st.
Sebastian's church is still standing
it was garlanded with fresh flowers for
the funeral but this is still a crime
scene at least a hundred and ten people
were murdered here according to the
church Maria's family home is just a
hundred metres down the street friends
and family were here for the work
the memory of the attack is still raw to
other cities data
their pain is deep and personal but when
the bells tolled the whole of negombo
answered and came to pay their respects
there is too much grief for one town too
much even for the whole of Sri Lanka Tom
Cheshire Sky News negombo